this laundry will probably never be
taken in by the women who hung it out to
dry the self-declared state of
nagorno-karabakh vanished so quickly its
ethnic Armenian population had only
minutes to pack
the rapid Exodus driven by fears of
ethnic cleansing by Azerbaijan
few people accepted assurances from the
government in Baku that they would be
safe the real problem is that
my feet just took stuck to the ground
I don't know but I just can't live I
know that I have to I know
but I'm not ready for that people hidden
bomb shelters when Azerbaijan launched
its lightning military offensive on
nagorno-karabakh as Russian Peacekeeper
stood aside it didn't take long for the
azerbaijanis to break through the ethnic
armenian's thin defenses
nine days later and most of the
population of 120 000 has gone those
still here are trying to leave it is
impossible to find fuel I met a woman
they are ready to pay like 200 dollar
for five kilometer fuel I don't know
when other patterns will arrive here I
have some fears like
um and I don't want they arrive you know
and I'm not ready to to met them over 30
years tens of thousands of people have
died fighting for and against the
self-declared Republic of
nagorno-karabakh now almost in an
instant it's gone it is for the
Armenians and National tragedy now the
government here must try and accommodate
a sudden and unexpected influx of as
many as 40 000 families
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera Yerevan
arminius prime minister Nicole passion
is urging the International Community to
act against what he calls ethnic
cleansing
in a few days there will be no more
Armenians left in nagorno-karaba this is
an act of ethnic cleansing and depriving
people of their Homeland something we
have been warning the International
Community about for a long time as for
Armenia are prior to now is to receive
our brothers and sisters to put it from
Nago nakaraba as careful as possible and
provide their needs